we revised the idea of future value
yesterday
uh can anyone give me like a one
sentence definition future value is
what you want to try and
redeem yourself value into the future
that was exactly
the quality answer that i came here for
okay so the idea
is we have an annuity right we're
putting regular installments in
those installments are all an interest
at some point in the future
you know after some amount of time some
number of years some number of months
whatever
this would be what it's worth right
that's the idea of future value okay
and so we um we had this guy right this
graph
that was to suggest if we do this
process of
installment interest installment
interest installment interest you get
the idea
right we end at some upper value
okay now you'll really need to think
hard for this one and it was on the
graph that we had a look at yesterday
how does that connect to present value
this is where we'll be some number of
years or months into the future
present value is something over here
right what is it
can anyone remember have a think it's
more complicated so if you can't
remember that's okay
but i wonder if anyone does the question
again yeah um
what is how do we define present value
if we defined future value as what's
what's that sum
over there that you'll get to after a
certain amount of time
then how do we define present value do
you want to have a stab
yeah if i recall it's uh how much money
would you have to install
now to be equivalent to the
accumulated value yeah yeah yeah i
reckon we're 90
there so of course the name says present
value it's about
you know if this is our time axis right
as we go further and further into the
future as we go to the right okay
so we're looking at something now
presently it's a certain value that
if you just put it in the bank didn't do
installments or anything like that just
took this big sum of money
popped it in there and let it gather
interest
it would get you to that same point
that's the idea
okay now this table enables us just like
the tables we looked at yesterday
to calculate these present values but
one of the things you'll notice about it
is um
this is a different kind of table okay
if you
if you can have a look at yesterday's
table and compare it to this one
okay the first thing you'll notice is as
you'd hoped
in yesterday's table which is about
future values all the numbers
are bigger than one and i say that again
look at the table
in yesterday's table for future values
all the numbers are bigger than one
you'd hope so because they they have to
be right because they're getting bigger
right well if one year is a single match
you can't have a future value after
one like once um yeah okay so
that's where you begin right after one
year okay but i want you to notice have
a look and this is kind of like the big
glaring like huh what's going on here
look at the top row
or not that like this row have a look at
the first set of numbers that actually
mean something
these are all zero point something why
is that
hmm now you might think oh does this
have to do with depreciation that's when
you buy something and instead of
increasing value over time it decreases
in value it's not exactly what's going
on sophie what are you thinking
um is that just the interest
that's like because if you put it in at
the beginning of the year let's say
it does gather interest over time before
you do that
yep is that what that is it's pretty
close it's pretty close uh
sorry i'll throw to you and then we'll
see because i don't we could conjecture
about this for a long time but what do
you reckon
i just noticed like the more the
the goes up the small the smaller the
point this one is right correct so
instantly you're charging interest on
the loan
okay okay okay so we're getting on the
right we're getting we're getting warmer
here okay
i hope you have noticed i'll come to you
in a second zacky um i hope you've
noticed yes there are patterns here even
if you're not sure what the numbers mean
you can clearly see as you get closer
and closer to the right for some reason
these numbers are getting smaller and
smaller you're like why is that isn't
more interest rate like more
more better like that's going to make
your investment worth more
in the long term right i want you to
think again this goes yesterday's table
right
at what point in the year did we put the
installment in
did we put it at the start we did not
put it at the start of the year we put
it at the
end of the year right which is why at
the end of the year how much do you have
for that dollar
just a dollar didn't have any time to
earn interest do you remember that okay
but the whole idea of present value
present value is
well if i looked at it from now
and looked at my dollar at the end of
the year how much would i have now to
get to that one dollar
right well well right now if i say for
example
today put in 99.01 cents
if i put it in today it would actually
earn
one percent interest over the course of
the year right
so then guess what happens by the end of
that first year you're 99 cents
what's it going to turn into answer a
dollar does that make sense
now of course these numbers do get
bigger because we're putting more and
more dollars in
but this is the fundamental difference
between a present value table and a
future value table and it's why
as serene pointed out quite accurately
this number over here is
much smaller because if you only had
83.33
and put that at the start of the year if
you could find some amazing institution
that would give you this much interest
then you'd get to a dollar by the end of
the year okay
much more likely than someone who would
give you that much interest you're more
likely to find someone who's going to
charge you
that much interest credit cards by the
way they're like 21 22 percent
interest so paid off
don't use a credit card for credit okay